200 jahre später und ich habe es auch
endlich mal geschafft den hammer aus
also denke ich muss sagen da steht ja
echt ein super
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
bei einem neuen video er leute ich habe
heute den lieben es geld dabei
was gilt es geht und zwar haben wir uns
zusammen überlegt also ich erzähl mal
kurz sowie dahinter ich habe ja vor 12
monaten war so ein video gemacht wo ich
so ein paar sachen sag ich mal ich finde
ich will jetzt nicht sagen entlarvt
haben aber so ein bisschen aufgedeckt
habe bezüglich rebecca ring dass ihr
halt ein paar von meinen ideen kopiert
hat meinen namen in den kommentaren
blockiert hat und so weiter
und es geht zum beispiel hat auch schon
öfter videos zu ihr gemacht wo es halt
um ähnliche themen ging oder sich halt
einfach über diese wie kann man das
nennen ja wir sind gut befreundet und
ich konnte ja die macht dann immer die
bios absichtlich scheiße und sagte so
etwas will ich ja nicht so als hätte sie
5 1 also die rebecca macht hat schon
ziemlich speziellen content und ich habe
mich schon sehr lustig gemacht genau und
das habe ich mir auch mal sehr gerne
angeguckt und ich habe ihm dann hat mal
geschrieben
ja was hältst du davon wenn wir
vielleicht beim nächsten mal wenn wieder
irgendwas sehr kurioses auf klopft uns
zusammen hinsetzen und uns das anschauen
ja
und deswegen sitzen wir heute vor einer
woche
vor einer woche kam das ging ja da muss
ich jetzt darüber lustig machen ich weiß
nein das ist halt so schwierig ja ich
habe nur kurz reingekriegt dann habe ich
wieder aufgehört der titel ist zu echten
meerjungfrau werden und man muss direkt
schon mal sagen dieses video dieses
video hat 83.000 likes und auch nur 2007
display also ist ja eigentlich nur eine
behinderte idee finde ich ja also man
fragt sich wirklich so aber ich glaube
man überschätzt ich meine wir sind ja
beide schon über 20 und rebecca als auch
seitlich oder sie kann sehr oder weg
könnte so fast 28 sein so man weiß nicht
21 820 schwierig zu sagen weil ich
glaube jeder zuschauer sagt so 3
beziehungsweise sind gerade noch so in
den kreißsaal gerade entbunden worden
und ja ich das gefühl ich denke es ist
nicht so ganz was da abging wurde 1992
also bolliger in einer woche hat sie
geburtstag
rehberg habe ich halte da rein am 27 da
müssen wir gratulieren oder wir müssen
aber die heiße phase einläuten
geburtsvorbereitung geht los du ja ok
aber ich hätte jetzt also 27 schon alt
ich hab die 28-jährige kopf stellen
könnte ja die die wird nicht so ganz
jung macht halt aber auch konnte für 28
jährige also auf jeden fall sitzen wir
heute um uns das video zu echten
meerjungfrau werden einen tag unter
wasser im pool schwimmen anzuschauen
unter wasser schwimmen also sie schon
nicht über dem wasser in der luft
darunter war sondern was man muss ja
mehrmals sein also das habe ich dir
geschickt und dort ist die noch gar
nicht angeschaut hast du gesagt ne also
offiziell nicht hinz gerne mit euch die
videos sind wenn die rauskommen und
freue mich einfach wird sagen wir jetzt
gingen gar nicht lange rum bei sg haben
wir noch ein paar hat gedreht den ihr
euch auch auf jeden fall anschauen
solltet nach diesem video ist in der
video beschreibung verlinkt das wird
bestimmt auch ganz lustig weil da geht
es dann glaub ich darum also immer wenn
du irgendwann einmal hast einfach
anrufen
[Musik]
ich muss erstmal sagen vorweg ich finde
das richtig interessant jetzt mit den
hier zu sitzen und uns das ganze schon
besser also das freut mich
die beste idee ist nicht ob es keine
gute idee ich das wirklich stimmt das
gericht erkenne ich schreibe meine
kommentare ist es euch zuletzt so
gegangen sondern erfolgslauf ich dachte
wenn ich so näher gebracht hat immer
kurz ist muss ich mal kurz auf uns ewig
dauert ich muss das mal da hätte ich
auch selber drauf kommen können oder du
bist schaut gemacht bei welchem youtube
ich bin mir eigentlich sicher das ist
auf jeden fall nicht selber ausgedacht
oder meinst du dich hat sich das video
angeschaut finde ich wirklich selber
ausgedacht kann kann sein kost also ja
vielleicht ging es ja auch so viel uns
halt einmal macht einfach richtig oder
falsch ist wenn jetzt denkt beckham wird
ihre gang durchs wasser schwimmen ich
glaube das funktioniert ich sogar ich
selber stelle mir vor dass ich nicht so
elegant durchs wasser schwimmen ist ja
auch so geil wie so enthusiastisch ist
also ich finde es also man muss sagen
die ist auf jeden fall voll bei der
sache und startet ihre videos immer mit
großer motivation zu recht so ich glaube
die könnte so kann also eine
dokumentation über den zweiten weltkrieg
kommentieren und die villa von hier
positiv was geht ab heute reden wir über
die menschlichen opfer des zweiten
weltkriegs wird mich jetzt eine richtig
schöne sehen was für diese einblendung
hat eben warum diese das ist das was das
logo von ariel oder es ist ich glaube
schon würde ich jetzt mal sagen oder
muss sich anzuschauen doch erklären was
eine meerjungfrau ist das kann sogar
auch sein
also ich weiß warum hat sie das
eingeblendete also erst dahinter
schimmert sind bisher so wie ich schon
okay dass ich echt nicht gedacht und wie
fühlt sich wirklich immer so ein
bisschen wie fischschuppen es ist fast
so als wenn die märchenfreunde kreuzung
aus mensch und fisch ja unfassbar
und da sitzen jetzt wirklich leute die
das so so die so richtig mitfiebern wie
sie jetzt diese scheiß lassen um das
jetzt das könnten jetzt vielleicht auch
die ein oder andere so ein bisschen
wieder als sonstige hemmschwelle von
oder unnötigen hate
griff von uns beiden jetzt ansehen aber
ich denke mir halt wirklich diese ideen
und umsetzungen und vor allem wie gleich
das video glaube ich weiter geht für
mich ist das einfach nur komplett um
das ist eine nötige eltville ist aber so
richtig klasse dass ich mal jetzt hier
eben auf den boden weil hier will ich ja
stehen und jetzt gucken wir mal wie
lange wie sein würde
egal
dieser enthusiasmus schockt ein übel
oder wirklich ich stelle mir so in
meinem kopf sowieso rebecca bringt so
kommentiert wieso milch schlecht wird
also ein teilweiser sowieso wenig
verstümmelt hey leute vorgeht echt nicht
gedacht dass die milch schlecht wird mit
der zeit voll kranz ein bisschen drunter
gehören an habe ich mich hier so ein
bikini-oberteil geholt ich glaube das
muss ich sogar sagen dass robert nicht
ein schön oder sieht aus als hätten wir
so ein schritt wollen lasst doch es war
nur das letzte mittel
naja aber deshalb erst mal probieren
muss wie sich diese flossenschwimmen wie
das kaufen so ist habe ich mir noch eine
rose eine taucherbrille geholt ich weiß
mittelblocker kostet neun euro 50 team
ist man aber eine professionelle taucher
wurde da hätte man auch mal ein bisschen
ich meine das video hat auch save 4000
euro umgesetzt oder ja ich habe
teilweise also ohne scheiß leute kann
man das schon mal raus sondern also ist
ja mittlerweile ist es so dass youtube
öfter sogar einen namen ich hab das
machen wenn ich so videos über ribéry
machte dann denkt youtube dass das video
von gering ist ja und dann verdient man
dreimal so viel wie mit meinen normalen
videos wenn ich daran verdient mega viel
mit den videos zeigt glaube ich auch ja
wenn ich mal gespannt was dieses video
umsetzt hier bei mir
rebecca der nächste mal 100 euro
taucherbrille müssen uns gibt es echte
ansage ich habe jetzt wirklich gerade
die flosse angezogen
das ist jetzt meine flosse angezogen was
mal versuche mich jetzt zum spiegel zu
bewegen leute wenn sie wirklich wollt
dass ich hier 20 stunden darin
verbringen
danke auch weil ich werde echt
nicht wirklich voran das ist dann so
halt die steigerung von dom weiße wenn
man auch nur 1 40 stunden experiment in
diesem klassement also die sache ist die
macht das natürlich nicht 24 stunden
lang ja dass wir die macht eine halbe
stunde
ja und dann so fast schon ein dunkles
licht ausgemacht impuls youtube 2009 10
sind also weißt du was unsere großeltern
nicht so gedacht haben so auch wir bauen
jetzt deutschland auf wird voll geil so
was wird im nächsten jahrtausend möglich
sein so menschen ziehen sich flossen
aber jetzt also wenn die halt wirklich
27 ist mir zum beispiel so wenn man das
eine oder andere video mal macht es ja
auch mal so die eine andere person zu
verlusten
und ich bin noch mal sieben jahre jünger
ja was passiert denn da bitte dann also
ich meine dass ich auf video bekannt
dass du ihre freundin also viel an ist
dieses kleine sie waren glaube ich
freundin und tälern macht halt so videos
wie die meisten fehlen wird der kurs ist
das ist so ein asiate und die hat ein
video gemacht game master will mich ohne
kondom [ __ ]
ich glaube keiner ist so hießen wieder
auf ihrem kanal ohne den titel ging
genau einfach so in die beschränkt das
ist so der freundeskreis ich glaube ich
dass da jemand ist ob mit jetzt ohne
stress heißt gibt es das noch ist video
kann sein ich weiß nicht ob die videos
löw das muss ich mir später mal angucken
200 jahre später und ich habe es auch
endlich mal geschafft
sieben hammer aus also denke ich muss
sagen da steht ja echt ein super das ist
wirklich schön aus aber bei mir ist
jetzt schon verdammt heiß und das wird
wirklich hart 64 wird es sogar dass hier
an keiner stelle dass irgendwo
hinterfragen punkte weil am anfang hat
sich schon gesagt ich weiß nicht ob es
eine gute idee ist man da etwa schon
kann es jetzt ja da kann ich mich
eigentlich ist keine gute und dann jetzt
steht sie vom spiegel fünf jungen fort
flosse bist du ja aber das ist es damit
rum zu latschen wobei das glaube ich
nicht so befähigt funktioniert wird ich
glaube ich muss echt auf dem boden
kriechen
wenn ich das für euch machen soll an der
ich bin echt gespannt wie das aufgeben
hört euch glaube aber leiden wie wäre es
eigentlich immer so ich habe oder die
die gemeinde die fans oder die wollen
immer nur das die welt leide
und ja wir wollen das projekt zu
meerjungfrau wird
großes pech weißt du das ist wirklich
extrem großes pech im video zu machen wo
man sich in den meeren frau aus mais
oder damit einfache 4000 euro umsatz
generiert sagt mein mann was ich lass
mal lasst mal ein spendenkonto aufmachen
würde also das ist ja kein schicksal
super mit wirklich zu sehen wie menschen
in deutschland so leiden ne ne da wird
etwas machen wenn man so an die leute
denken kein sauberes trinkwasser wird
das ist ja ein witz dagegen er also
wieder als nicht gegessen so ja ok toll
aber hast du schon mal reden frau
kostümen leute was geht schöne grüße aus
dem schnitt ich muss jetzt leiden an
dieser stelle sagen wir pausieren hier
erstmal weil das video geht insgesamt
über 20 minuten und ich habe mir gedacht
oder wir haben uns gesagt 20 minuten am
stück ist schon lange deswegen ist das
hier der erste part morgen kommt der
zweite fahrrad um genau die gleiche
uhrzeit bei sk aber gerade auch der
erste part vom zweiten part sozusagen
also das video beim online check so ganz
mit der beschreibung verlinkt abonniert
ihnen und wir sehen uns morgen will ich
trotzdem waren daumen nach oben freuen
und auf 130 alex w